hello everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today i'm doing a little vlog here um as
i am anticipating
baby being here any day now um i'm
actually filming this when i'm
about 33 weeks pregnant so i still have
a little bit longer to go but
you're probably watching this right
before or maybe depending if baby comes
early
right when i am giving birth i'm trying
to batch shoot as much as i can so that
i can
allow myself just a little bit of time
post birth to enjoy
the newborn life if you can enjoy
newborn life i don't know
but anyways i asked you guys what
questions you had for me
about pregnancy fertility this baby my
birth plan all that fun stuff and you
had so many great questions so i'm gonna
try to answer
some of the big ones that came up a lot
so
let's do this okay first big question
was
how are you going to deal with people
wanting to touch
and hold the baby in covered times
very good question and also a hard
question to answer because right now we
are about
two months out of when i'm supposed to
have this baby and a lot can happen with
regards to kovid
um in two months a lot has happened
within each two months that has gone by
since this whole thing happened in march
so it's very hard to know or anticipate
what life is going to be like then
but if things were to happen today um
right now as it stands we have bubbled
with our immediate family
so i would probably of course let our
nanny and
our um our immediate family hold the
baby
um and uh plus doctors and lactation
consultants and
any other allied health as well that
would only make sense
um but outside of that you know any
friends that would want to visit we can
do maybe backyard visits from a distance
any friends or family other than our
immediate family that want to
help they could drop off food
so if you live in the gta in toronto and
you want to help a new mom out
you come drop off some food for me give
me something good to eat
so next huge question one that i got
asked many times is
do you have any insecurities around your
body changing in pregnancy
and if so how are you dealing with these
insecurities
okay so i want to start by saying that
this is not something that i would
normally really kind of talk to
a lot on a public forum
mainly because i just want to be
cognizant that despite the fact that of
course
my body is changing and my body is
getting bigger as
happens in pregnancy normally of course
i have no experience living in a larger
body so while of course all people have
body insecurities and
all body insecurities are valid and
worthy of being acknowledged
and talking about um these are normal
things to be experiencing
for everybody um i'm just aware
and cognizant of my own body's privilege
and generally this would inform
who i would speak to about these kinds
of
issues so having said all of that if me
talking about my body changing in
pregnancy
is triggering or offensive to you please
by all means
do skip ahead so first of all i think a
lot of people think that body positivity
means
you know like looking yourself in the
mirror every single day and thinking
that you are just like
rocking it but to me body positivity
means
respecting your body it doesn't
necessarily mean
that you'll always be confident or
comfortable
with you know despite what happens to
your body so
weight gain is a normal healthy expected
part of
pregnancy but it doesn't mean that it's
necessarily
easy to watch your body change so
rapidly
or kind of not even recognize some
features of your body when you look at
yourself in the mirror
like i physically cannot do a lot of
things while i'm pregnant
that i very easily could do when i'm not
so like bending over to pick something
up
that my son dropped um is really hard on
my core and my knees right now my knees
are just
killing me um and you know even just
like shaving my legs
or other things down there i can't do it
anymore because i literally cannot
see them so in my first pregnancy with
my son a couple years ago
i really didn't gain that much weight
and
um and i remember you know even that was
a bit stressful for me because i get on
the scale every week
and maybe the weeks that i didn't gain
any weight i'd be worried that something
was wrong or when somebody would make a
comment
that i was so small it would actually
upset me
but of course the comments about me
being too small
were not nearly as uncomfortable as the
comments of me being
huge or looking so big and that's
because
our society has a very obvious hierarchy
when it comes to body size and body
shape but let's be real
any body comments are rude and just so
uncomfortable and cringe-worthy
and unfortunately it's become way too
normalized in our society
to make comments about pregnant body so
just heads up to everybody doesn't mean
if you are coming at it from a good
place
please just avoid making comments about
pregnant people's bodies
too big too small it doesn't matter i
just think that
it's not very kind then with this
pregnancy i had this expectation that i
wasn't
going to gain a lot of weight because
that's what happened with my last
pregnancy and when
you know you're a second time mom you
just kind of base everything off your
first experience
but i gained weight a lot faster this
time and
i knew that this was normal and healthy
even if it didn't feel normal to me
based on my last experience
but then people started to comment and
tell me oh my gosh you look so much
bigger
than you did last time as if that was
like a really great thing to say to
somebody
um and of course that made me worry that
something was wrong
and it turns out something actually was
wrong in that situation
my thyroid was low and correcting that
um
actually did slow down the weight gain a
little bit but still even at the time
of me filming this i'm two months out of
giving birth um
like 30 33 weeks now and
i have gained more than i did my entire
first pregnancy
and i'm actually okay with that honestly
most days i really don't even think
about it
because i just know my body is doing
what it has to do and
every pregnancy is so unique and
different
but on other days when i'm already
stressed by something
or somebody makes a mean comment online
or calls me out for being
huge or whatever and my resiliency is
already
kind of down um i of course have
insecure concerns like is this
the right weight gain amount for me and
the fact that i even have to think about
these things while living in a socially
accepted
body shape and size just points to
and speaks to how deeply ingrained fat
phobia
is and how problematic this per
like pervasive concept of bouncing back
really is in our society but yeah like
when a nurse weighs you and then makes
them off the cuff
comment about the weight gain coming on
fast you're
probably going to worry this is a
medical professional making a comment
you know even if you inherently trust
your body
to lead the way there's going to be that
like little voice in the back your head
being like
oh is something wrong here should i be
concerned
um so yeah sidenote fyi for everybody
who's watching
pregnancy weight gain is not linear or
perfect it does not have to be
the perfect one to one and a half pounds
per week that your app tells you you
should be
gaining every body and every pregnancy
is different and unique and that's the
one that i even had to remind myself of
during this process when obviously my
weight gain was not linear
so yeah sometimes i think that those
apps kind of freak
moms out so believe me i have a
ton of empathy for those of you who want
to change your body whether it's in
pregnancy or
you know after pregnancy or has nothing
to do with pregnancy
i think it's almost impossible not to
want to change your body
in a society that really hates fatness
even if you're not fat but while we
can't necessarily change the world and
society's view on body shape
and body size we can change how we
respond
to it the first thing we can do is to
acknowledge these thoughts and also to
acknowledge
how deep seated fat phobia really is in
basically all of us and the other is to
not let these thoughts interfere with
how we treat
our body i may worry about what other
people may think about me as a dietitian
and
bouncing back fast enough but the
reality is this is not going to change
how i nourish my body both for
pregnancy to grow a baby to heal from a
birth
and pregnancy and to feed a baby through
breastfeeding
and speaking of breastfeeding it really
irks me and bothers me when people just
make the statement oh don't even worry
about gaining weight or
all the fat that you've gained uh it's
all just gonna melt away once you have
that baby and you start breastfeeding
when actually this is only the
experience of about half of women
where a lot of us myself included need
the extra fat
and weight on our body to feed baby so i
actually gain weight
while breastfeeding and actually a lot
of people do um so
even though of course body changes in
pregnancy are uncomfortable and i feel
like i have
some added pressure on me being a
dietitian and working in the media and
being in the public eye and i have a lot
of trolls
and those trolls are vicious and are not
sensitive to the fact that i'm growing a
human right now um
but i will say that my priority is and
always has been and will continue to be
growing and feeding a healthy baby
that is my priority and that is what
kind of helps to
get me through some of those insecure
moments okay
next question is what does maternity
leave
look like for you as a youtuber very
good question
i'm not sure i didn't really take that
much time off with my first i actually
remember
being at the hospital and answering
emails and negotiating contract
like in between contractions like kind
of rocking back and forth like breathing
and
trying to write an email it took me a
little longer than
normal um and also i went it did my
first tv segment
two weeks postpartum because it was a
mother's day segment and they really
wanted me on because i was a new mom
and my son was in the green room waiting
for me watching me on the big screen so
that was uh that was my first matt leave
this time i did tell my agent that i
would like um
at least three or four weeks minimum
before
i do any kind of live tv or live
appearances
or even have to do a shoot day so i'll
take a few weeks off of shooting in my
studio
um and also just like recipe testing too
like i'd like to not be
having to do any of these more strenuous
long days that i normally do in the
studio
um but other than that you know i'll be
answering emails and writing content and
editing content doing all the
behind-the-scenes work so that
when i do feel like i got a little bit
more sleep in me and a little bit more
resilience that i can get back
into the studio and bang some more good
stuff out we have been working ours off
here behind the scenes to kind of bank
some content so that i don't feel like
we get behind
i don't know i'm a real stickler for my
schedule and i know you guys think that
it's unnecessary and i'm i'm welcome to
take time off etc
but i don't know i just like to have my
schedule and and try to stick to it as
best as i can so i'm going to
try my best for that now of course not
knowing what life is going to be like
with a toddler
and a newborn i would love to have some
other ideas on really more simple vlog
style content that i can produce
so that if i'm just exhausted or i just
don't have the bandwidth or the time to
do
as many what in a day reviews and things
like that because those take me like a
week
just to do the research for um so if you
have any other ideas please leave me a
comment below
i want to keep giving you great content
i want to make sure that it's
evidence-based and awesome
but of course i also have no idea what
my life is going to be like
very soon okay next question is any
newborn essentials that you're
definitely going to be using
this time around yeah actually
that's a really good question i've
almost like blocked out that whole
time in my life so i need to kind of
revisit what i have
actually i haven't even like done gone
and organized
everything yet but a few things off the
top of my head
one a good breast pump so i exclusively
pumped for a year with my son so i had
a lot of different breast pumps that i
tried um i have a ton of them
and my favorite that i own is the
medulla
sonata medela medela sonata i don't know
how you thought medulla medella
um sonata this one i found way more
comfortable
and i have got way better output um than
my
spectra which everyone raves about the
spectra but i found the spectra
a super duper loud and b
i just found that it it was like really
aggressive like it
really ruined my nipples i got mastitis
every single time i used it
but my sonata no problems it was super
quiet
very powerful great output so if you
want to invest in a really amazing pump
the sonata is amazing um but this time i
got the willow pump
as another backup which are it's kind of
cool because it goes like right into
your bra it's completely wireless
cordless so this i'm hoping will make it
easier for me to pump on the go because
i used to have to like
pump in the car and like pump when i
went for brunch and
i did it it was just so awkward to have
to do all the time and i hated doing it
so i think if i could be a little bit
more discreet
um that will be amazing and it'll make
my pumping
journey a little easier on me um other
things that i
loved was the merlin magic suit
this was so great we put my son in this
as soon as he was big enough to fit into
it
but it basically is like a full body
swaddle that's safe
so when you swaddle like a newborn of
course their hands are kind of tucked
under but
the first time the only time i ever
swallowed my son like that he decided to
roll over and it was traumatizing and he
screamed and i thought he was gonna die
anyways it was a horrible experience so
i didn't want that
the merlin suit is arms and legs that
are hugged them nice and tightly
so they feel like this they're kind of
swaddled and tight and cozy
and hugged but they sleep so much better
than without it so that was so
so key another really important
essential was the dr newman's nipple
ointment
this was so key if you are pumping or
breastfeeding
and of course you're gonna get sore
nipples it's inevitable but this was the
only nipple cream that actually
helped and you can ask your doctor to
add some ibuprofen
to the formula if you go to a
compounding pharmacist
and this will also add some kind of pain
relief as well if you're if you're
struggling with
pain which you probably are um
and what else um oh and the bouncer we
had the baby
we have the baby bjorn bouncer which is
amazing there's so many different swings
and like
you know electronic rockers and things
my kid hated all of those expensive
items the bouncer was the best one that
we
ever tried and so i'm i'm hoping that
this new
child likes it as well but it's great to
just like strap them into the bouncer
give them a toy and you can do something
else whether it's making dinner or
pumping or just answering the door or
whatever you don't always have to have
them
in your hands so we love the baby bjorn
i actually have a whole blog post
um about newborn essentials and then
also essentials from
the the month 6 to 12. so i'm gonna
leave a link to that
in the description below so definitely
check that out next question
of course another big one what is your
birth plan and how is covid affecting
this
very good question i mean you know me
i'm a planner i like to plan
um and i actually started this pregnancy
out with an
ob and i had no b with my son but we
also had a doula
and that doula helped um enormously with
birth support i i couldn't imagine
after the fact i said that was the best
decision we made in the whole thing was
having that doula
um but then of course covet happened and
we were told that we can only have one
support partner in the hospital
so i felt like of course i want to bring
my husband
and that meant no doula so we switched
to a midwife because this way at least i
felt like
you know at least if my doula can't be
there by august and i have no idea
what's going to happen by then
that at least i'll have some birth
support a little bit more so with the
midwife
than i would with no bee because the ob
really only kind of comes in when it's
time to catch the baby
the other thing is that i really hated
staying over
in the hospital it was the worst part of
the whole birthing experience was having
to stay over
in the hospital in a shared room with
another family
and another crying baby and it's just
it still gives me a bit of anxiety and
nightmares
and at least with a midwife i could go
home pretty much immediately after birth
assuming that
all things go well and they can check on
me at home and especially with kovid i
really just want to get the hell out of
that hospital as fast as i humanly
possibly can so my birth plan is to go
into labor
naturally hopefully because i was
induced last time and i
really want to avoid another induction
that was another reason why i want to
switch to the midwife is because
the ob wants to induce all ivf patients
and i just don't see the reason for that
so
there's no evidence to support that that
recommendation at all even though that's
the kind of like
standard protocol so my midwife doesn't
think that's necessary so i'm hoping to
go into labor naturally
and then i'll probably just labor at
home as long as i possibly can
manage and then head off to the hospital
and meet my
midwife there and depending on how
things are looking in august when i give
birth
maybe my doula can come as well please
i'm really really
trying to be helpful and of course i'll
go as long as i possibly can
pain wise i i had to be induced last
time so if i need another induction
and it becomes so intense that i need an
epidural
i'll get an epidural i don't need to be
a hero i got an epidural last time
and it was great so the only thing that
makes me
consider kind of getting the epidural
sooner than later like
you don't want to wait so long and then
it'd be too late for you to get the
epidural was that
last time i had two two inductions the
first one failed
um and then they did another one and so
i had already gone eight
hours with intense contractions because
i was
on pitocin and my contractions were like
on top of each other
and the nurse was like oh that's usually
a sign that it's time to push
you're probably ready to go and i was
like great after eight hours of that i
was like great
i can't believe i made it i can't
believe i did it um and then they
checked me and i was four
centimeters dilated and obviously you
gotta get to ten and i was like
no way no way in hell i need the
epidural now i can't go another six
centimeters
like this and it ended up being another
12 hours on top of that
um so it was a 20 hour labor plus i had
a retained placenta
and if you know what that means it
basically meant that the doctor had to
put
his whole arm up into me literally um
while the doctor and the resident were
like punching on my stomach
trying to get the placenta to
dislodge and that caused me to
hemorrhage so there were a lot of things
that happened that
makes me kind of grateful that i had
pain relief on board
so yeah honestly i'm just gonna play
this one by ear i don't have any hard
and fast rules when it comes to
whether or not i'm getting the epidural
or when i'm getting the epidural i'm
just gonna hope that
i don't need to be induced that it's a
relatively fast labor
and that i don't have a retained
placenta or hemorrhage this time
wish me luck okay next question
any recommendations for moms who want to
have a full-time career
yes delegate delegate delegate
i mean you cannot do it all you really
have to
get as much help as you possibly can and
just relinquish some control it's just
it's impossible to do it all i think
that mothers and fathers who choose to
work have to really consider
two major things versus the professional
and just emotional fulfillment of their
career and
second is the financial aspect of it i
personally love what i do and i would
not feel
fulfilled in my life if i did not have
my career now
other mothers or fathers may not feel
this way about their jobs and
and or the idea of motherhood or
parenthood or fatherhood
may be so strong that it totally
overshadows
that job and that is amazing too i also
recognize that delegating some of the
work in my business to
my assistant or to freelancers and some
of the child care to
our nanny or to you know leaning on
family and things like that
made more financial sense to my business
than just stepping back
and not working at all now i recognize
that i am
very very privileged to be able to make
those choices because
there are so many women and men out
there who who may want to work
but can't because it doesn't make
financial sense or
maybe they want to stay home with their
children and they can't because it does
not make financial sense so again i
am so lucky to have the privilege to be
able to make those choices for
myself but again bottom line i think
relinquishing some control
is key okay next question how would your
life be different
if you had your kids 10 years ago
probably very different um 10 years ago
i was 22 years old
i was in school and also probably just
not in the best emotional place
in my life i was struggling really hard
with my anxiety and also remnants of my
orthorexia
and my priority and my goal was to just
succeed at school
and get into a good internship at any
cost
i'm not really sure that i would have
been able to deal
so well with the changes the body
changes
the the relationship changes the
responsibility changes
that comes with motherhood i was also
just
starting the abby's kitchen blog and and
i think if i had had my family back then
i probably would not have
had the momentum and the bandwidth to
really build it
into what it is today so i'm not even
sure that this channel would even be a
thing
if i had my kids 10 years ago okay
next question how does being a dietitian
impact
how you feed your kids great question
i think there is this thought that being
a dietitian means that i
am obsessed with ensuring that every
single meal
that my child eats is perfectly balanced
and super nutritious and organic and
free of any sugar or gluten or whatever
but honestly that's not how i roll if
anything
being a dietitian has made me a bit more
relaxed about feeding
my son um and i always say that i am
way more concerned with the long-term
game
of raising a competent intuitive eater
then i am concerned about how much
vitamin a
my kid gets in a single given day so i
follow
a feeding theory called the division of
responsibility which was developed by
ellen satter who was
really like the child and and toddler
and
and
teen feeding guru but basically what it
entails is that
as a parent i am responsible for what
food is served
when the food is served where the food
is served
and my son or the child is responsible
for
what he eats and if he eats at all
so i will do a whole video on this if
that's something that you're interested
in
but basically i don't pressure or bribe
my son to eat anything you know
i really want him to learn how to listen
to his hunger and fullness cues
and i want to make the meal time a
pleasant experience
so that meals don't become like a
battleground and there's a neutrality
around food like nothing is good and
nothing is bad so i serve a wide variety
of foods
in balanced meals that i would eat
myself and i always try to kind of
switch things up so that he's seeing a
variety of fruits and a variety of
vegetables and grains
and and fats and proteins etc
i want to make sure that he's getting
exposed to a wide variety of food so
we're not always seeing
the same like five foods on rotation
that i know of course
that he likes now the key is that i
always want to make sure that there is
at least
one safe food or like a fallback food
on the table at all times that when all
else fails
if he doesn't like the vegetable i'm
serving and if he doesn't like the
protein i'm serving or the spice mix
that i put in or whatever
he at least can eat that food so that
might be bread for a lot of kids that
might be
rice for a lot of kids maybe it's a
fruit or a vegetable or a piece of
chicken or whatever i mean all kids are
going to have their preferences
and i also serve fun foods as well and
sometimes i serve unlimited amounts of
fun foods basically i let the kid eat
adlibitum at certain snacks
so that it takes the novelty factor away
from those sweets or those foods
but of course we don't want to
necessarily serve unlimited sweets at
the same time as dinner
because it may kind of take away from or
crowd out
other nutritious foods in the diet so
these are all components of the division
responsibility that i'll really need to
go into more detail on but the reality
is i also don't let my son
completely dictate what he gets served
if he throws a tantrum at the dinner
table because you know he wants it only
a banana
for example and that day you know i've
made sure that there's a safe or
fallback food on the table i don't give
him a banana
i would calmly say to him oh you know
tonight we're having bread i know you
like bread and we're having chicken
and we're having peas and we're having
broccoli um but maybe tomorrow we'll
have
a banana but if the banana is on the
table and that is one of the foods that
i've chosen
to serve to him then i don't withhold
the banana to get him to eat
a piece of broccoli instead there has to
be no pressure there has to be
a moral neutrality around these foods
again the division responsibility would
say
that i as the parent choose what is
served and he decides
what if anything he's gonna eat there's
a lot to unpack here so of course i'm
gonna have to go into
a lot more detail in a full video but i
will tell you that this
method absolutely does work my son does
not eat perfectly but that is not my
goal anyways
he has a really balanced diet over time
and he eats intuitively and to me
that is winning so some days he will go
for the broccoli first on the plate
and other days he will go for the safe
food like the
the bread or the rice and the other day
i even offered him a slice of
really amazing key lime pie and it was
so so delicious
and he was full so what did he do he
took two bites
and he said mommy i'm done and he handed
me the bowl that my friend says pretty
good evidence that the division of
responsibility
even though it sounds crazy to a lot of
parents really does work
so success in feeding to me is not that
my son
never eats fast food or never eats sugar
or never wants to eat sugar
success to me is that he is able to
listen to his body
and he doesn't put certain foods in a
hierarchy
like a moral hierarchy of this one's
yucky this one's yummy
this is good this is bad anyways like i
said if you want a whole video on this
let me know in the comments below
and also i have a really amazing feeding
group on facebook that i run called the
millennial mom's
guide to mindful meal planning so if you
want to join that i'll leave a link to
that in the description
as well next question do you struggle
with work
life balance so much
so much i mean it's probably my biggest
source of anxiety and guilt because i
really do not know how to
successfully successfully be a mother
and run a very big business and busy
business
without feeling an enormous amount of
mom guilt
i actually wrote a whole post about this
in my last pregnancy because i was
feeling it back then and now
i feel like my business is even busier
and bigger and
i honestly feel like i'm just treading
water i really do
feel like i'm failing at everything at
times because i can't do
everything to my very high standards and
that is my fault
i am actively trying to lower my
standards but
it doesn't really come naturally to me
because you know type a personality
right here
my husband is a lot better at this and i
think a lot of men are because
i just think that they don't put as much
pressure on themselves
um like for example he'd be happy to
order uber eats
you know every night of the week just to
take that pressure off the family
but for me i feel like i take a lot of
pride in certain aspects of my work
and motherhood that i feel like i am
good at like food
so it's a little bit harder for me to
let those things go
but i also know that ultimately i put
all this pressure on myself because
ultimately i
am probably my worst critic but yeah i
basically always just feel like i'm
not doing enough or not doing it good
enough okay
next question any food tips for pregnant
or new
moms yes batch
prep if you are pregnant right now and
you are making
anything just for regular dinner make a
huge
batch of it and freeze some of it for
later for when the baby is born
i'm telling you when we had our first
kid
i think i lasted like two full months on
batch prepped meals which is amazing
and and that really did get me through
also
if you are a new mom accept any food
that
anyone is willing to make for you or buy
for you or send to you
do not worry that it's not as healthy or
perfect or organic or balanced than what
you would normally
make for yourself just feed yourself or
have
somebody else feed you period also
having snacks on hand postpartum is so
key
you're going to be so busy you're not
going to be able to make meals or even
eat meals
so just having things that you can
quickly pop in your mouth is amazing
so if you want to do some batch prepping
while you're pregnant some really kind
of simple
muffin recipes energy balls lactation
cookies
smoothie packs those kind of things are
going to save
your life and also any kind of package
snacks that you like and enjoy
make sure that you are stocked up on
them because i think i lift off like
kind bars and like
pistachios for those late night feeds or
just those days when i was just so
exhausted
where i couldn't really do anything else
like i couldn't really prepare
any kind of meal for myself there wasn't
even time to actually eat
the meal never mind prepare it so yeah
batch prep
and snack it up okay did you always know
that you wanted to be a mom
i did actually um my mother is an
amazing mom and also as an entrepreneur
so i knew that i actually wanted to
to have both she when i was growing up
ran
montessori school she was a principal
she was a teacher and she was invested
in the montessori method so
i did a lot of the after school programs
and the after school care
and babysitting and things like that so
i really grew up
so fascinated by children and fascinated
by their development
so i definitely knew always that i
wanted to be a mom
but still motherhood is actually really
really hard for me it's really
challenging for everyone but i
i don't know doesn't necessarily come
naturally to me um
and it's way harder for me than my work
my day job that's for sure
way more work than my day job um but
still yes there was never a doubt in my
mind that
i wanted to be a mom okay how am i
feeling physically in this pregnancy
compared to with baby e oh
brutal baby ease pregnancy
was so easy in comparison
honestly i was like modestly sick but
really not that bad just in the first
trimester
i never had any pains no no back pain at
all
i was literally doing spinning classes
until like the week i gave birth
legit this time well i'm almost three
years older so there's that
and i also went through a lot more to
get pregnant this time so i feel like i
was already like battered
and bruised by the time i got here but i
will say i was
more sick in the first trimester this
time not like hospitalized
grades certainly i mean a lot of my
friends have it way worse but more so
than with baby e
also way more tired like dizzying tired
by 3 p.m
um and it's still exhausting i mean that
wasn't just like a first or second
trimester thing it was like i'm just
wiped all the time and this baby is
way more active like i'm talking full on
somersaults like cirque du soleil style
all day all night to the point that
sometimes i have to walk on the
treadmill at like 1 00 a.m
just to get this baby to cool down and
and fall asleep just to give me like a
minute
to breathe also baby e was a winter
pregnancy summer pregnancies
suck oh honestly i can only go outside
for like 30 minutes because i have to
wear compression socks
all day every single day otherwise my
feet are like just throbbing by the end
of the day
and when i i went for a walk 30 minutes
just 30 minutes
early in the morning 8 a.m just to avoid
the heat with poppy the other day
and my hand blew up so big they're
getting so hot and big
that i involuntarily dropped her leash
because i couldn't bend my fingers
so i'm finding that even by like 3 p.m
every single day now
my fingers are so are so swollen that
i'm having a hard time just typing and
doing my
job so i'm like holding on to ice packs
now just to go out for a walk for 30
minutes with the dog it's
it's it's uncomfortable but all
complaints aside
i am so so so grateful that this
ivf cycle worked because my goodness to
be stuck
in ivf limbo during covet times
is excruciating i have so much empathy
for all of my infertility warriors out
there especially i mean it's it's
terrible on a good day
but during these covet times where
you're also dealing with the stress of
that
and having to wait for cycles to be you
know started back
up and cycles being cancelled i can only
imagine
so you know all of you are so so strong
so
don't ever hesitate to reach out if you
if you need someone to talk to
and you need a little bit of support
because i think what you guys must be
going through must be absolute
hell okay next question are you worried
about breastfeeding this time around
guys i'm so stressed about this already
i was stressed about this as soon as i
stopped breastfeeding and pumping with
my son
then the first thought i had was uh i am
just counting down the days to when i
have to do this again
but yes i had a really rough time
breastfeeding my son and i talked about
it in my video here
um but he basically had what the dentist
called the worst
lip and tongue tie that she had ever
released so that was great
um and then on top of that i had supply
issues i had to pump every hour on the
hour
for months take down paradigm to get my
supply up which caused massive anxiety
issues
plus my son had colic which was not fun
and i had my status like five times so
yeah it was a really really rough go and
i had to give up breastfeeding because
it just was
too emotionally exhausting for me to
even try when it just wasn't working so
i
exclusively pumped for over a year and i
remember when i got home
from the hospital after a very
frustrating night trying to breastfeed
my son in the hospital
which obviously wasn't working and i
told the lactation consultant the
lactation consultant came over like the
next day that i i came home
and she i told her that the first night
you know we had to give
my son a bit of formula because i just
didn't have any milk
and she audibly gasped and said
oh no now imagine being already sleep
deprived and so frustrated just trying
your absolute damn best
and that was that was the response that
i got honestly the culture of
breastfeeding shaming is so intense and
aggressive
not all people want to or can
breastfeed and that is totally okay like
what i've come to realize
is that fed is absolutely best
do i want to have a breastfeeding
relationship this time yes
so badly do i hate that stupid pump with
every bone in my body yes
so much but i will say that you know by
the end of the year
i did feel like so accomplished so proud
of myself that i had
frozen i'd gone from being an
undersupplier and really killing myself
to to get that milk into my sun
to being an over supplier with freezing
over a hundred liters
of excess breast milk that brought my
son into the second year of life and
that's basically what he consumed
for several months in his second year so
it all felt pretty rewarding even though
it literally killed me to make it
but i would probably do the ivf
experience over a million times before
dealing with
all of the roadblocks and struggles that
i experienced in breastfeeding
again so i'm just really hoping
that things run more smoothly this time
please
please pray for me okay has your diet
changed in
pregnancy not really honestly i haven't
had any aversions or really any cravings
this pregnancy
my last pregnancy i didn't really have
any cravings but i definitely had
aversions to
fish and chicken just and eggs basically
a lot of proteins i couldn't eat them at
all the whole pregnancy it took months
after
giving birth for me even to want a
chicken breast again
but i really haven't dealt with any of
those things so that hasn't really
changed i probably eat one more snack a
day than i normally would but i'm really
it's not something that i'm tracking i'm
just
listening to my body and i'm if i'm more
hungry i eat a little bit more
and that's basically what i do so it's
certainly not something that i'm very
cognizant of
i don't eat any raw fish while i'm
pregnant um i also don't crave it
so that helps and i also don't drink
alcohol or then maybe a sip of my
husband's wine on the occasional weekend
but other than that yeah i'm just trying
not to stress too much over things
because
i feel like covid has been enough of a
stressor in these times
okay next question how did giving birth
feel and did it hurt okay
so great question and trigger warning
that
uh this might get graphic and gross for
some of you so
feel free to skip ahead if that's
triggering or weird for you
um but yeah i was induced so my labor
was pretty intense
um i did i think i mentioned before i
did eight hours of like
really intense contractions like there'd
be like three contractions on top of
each other
before i'd even get like even a few
seconds of relief
and they thought that that meant that it
was time to push of course but it
actually only meant that i was four
centimeters dilated and i was dying
so i got the um epidural at that point
and i was grateful that i did because it
was like another 12 hours on top of that
so at that point i got a little bit of
rest and i really needed that rest
because i had an induction
the night before that failed and that
induction had me having like
really intense labor pains in the night
which kept me up so i didn't sleep
and then eventually i passed out and
when i woke up it was like
oh it stopped ugh it stopped it means i
have to go in again
and have it a new induction started so
that really sucked
but how does it feel it's hard to
describe but i think it feels kind of
like
um period cramps times like 100 or a
thousand
i don't really know i haven't done the
math exactly
so i don't know scientifically how many
more times
painful it is compared to a normal
period cramp
but like period cramps kind of like your
insides are being
twisted um and also it's exhausting like
i remember
going through like with my doula going
through like exercises breathing
exercises to try to get through each
contraction
and like my legs would be shaking by the
end and i was in really good shape then
i was spinning like every day so
i was physically exhausted and drained
by the the kind of marathon that is
labor
and i really don't know what pushing
like the sensation of the
what they call the ring of fire feels
like because i had an epidural at that
point
and i also don't know what tearing feels
like because i didn't tear
what i do want moms to do and to know is
to not
be afraid um i actually cannot wait for
labor again it was so exciting
you know even the pain of it that those
kind of memories almost fade away
because
the pushing part like that hour of
pushing was the most exciting
exhilarating hour of my life
it was literally like having a room full
of supportive people
cheering you on telling you you're
amazing telling you how strong you are
and how awesome that push was like it
was so
so exciting and and even though i had a
bit of a like traumatic post birth
experience where
i had the postpartum hemorrhage and i
had the retained placenta and the
pushing and the
beating of on my belly thinking about
those things
is a little bit scary but the pushing
experience and just
the adrenaline rush and holding the baby
in your arms afterwards
it was so so amazing and as soon as i as
soon as it happened as soon as the baby
came out i said i turned to my husband i
said
can we do that again because it was just
it was just so cool
the whole experience was just so cool so
yeah don't be afraid
it was the experience is just so
incredibly
fun okay next question what will my
postpartum diet
look like honestly probably like
whatever
i feel like and also probably a lot of
it i was super hungry last time when i
was breastfeeding and i
expect things will be the same this time
um but yeah probably a lot of soups i
froze
i've i've already frozen like 15 bags of
homemade soup in the freezer so i'll
probably be having a lot of that because
i know last time i was craving a lot of
you know hydration and water so that was
really key
um also i ate a lot of watermelon so
this time at least watermelon will be
more in season so i'll probably have a
lot of that
and then lots of snacks right like tons
of
nuts and bars i love kind bars i always
had those
i love dips so hummus and guacamole
higher calorie snacks like that
that are really easy to to reach for and
grab
and also yogurt i mean i love yogurt and
greek yogurt
even when i'm not breastfeeding and
nursing so probably a lot of yogurt
because i also know that my protein and
my
calcium needs are going to be extra high
while nursing so
those are the kind of things that i'm
probably going to be eating a lot of
things that are really super easy to
grab
and just shove in my face really quickly
because i'm probably not going to have a
whole lot of time for super fancy meals
have you been exercising during your
pregnancy
yes actually and i think there's a huge
misconception that you you can't
exercise and i actually address this in
my
pregnancy myth video but honestly not a
whole lot has changed my exercise regime
um i'm not doing hit workouts obviously
and i never
really was i haven't for a long time at
least because a i don't enjoy them and b
you know even before i was pregnant it
just wasn't really great for my
fertility
um but i walk daily either inside on the
treadmill on an
incline or outside with my husband and
my kid
so i try to enjoy the outdoors while i
can and it's not too hot and my hands
aren't blowing up
um but i'm also doing like a combination
of strength training like weight lifting
and like bar workouts sometimes with my
virtual trainer
and sometimes i do a lot of like um
youtube videos so i love
sydney cummings videos if you are not
familiar with her
youtube workouts they're amazing so
definitely check that out but of course
i'm always interested in hearing
some other great youtubers that you love
to to to follow along with their
workouts so leave me some comments and
ideas below
but yeah i don't do a lot of ab stuff
definitely not like any like twisting
moves
um i have diastasis recti from my first
pregnancy and a little bit of prolapse
so i definitely don't want to make that
any worse in this pregnancy if i can
avoid it
um and i don't do any workout moves that
really get me
out of breath so definitely less
compound moves
more kind of static arms a lot of booty
band
moves things like that a lot of back
exercises
because honestly pregnancy and
breastfeeding both kind of get you to
like
slump over which is not a great look not
great for my posture
um but yeah i just feel best when i'm
exercising it
definitely helps with energy levels and
it definitely helps with sleep
and digestion so i do try to keep
active in pregnancy okay last question
how is big boy e feeling about the baby
and being a big brother
so he's so cute he's so affectionate he
will come up to me
and like hug my belly and say mama's
baby
and give it a kiss and stroke it very
gently he knows to be very gentle
he's actually gonna be a really great
big brother because
you know as far as boys go he's very
affectionate i know everyone complains
oh boys are so wild
not my boy my boys is a very loving he
loves to cuddle he loves his teddies and
his
his baby doll that we we've been
practicing on
um i expect that he may be a little bit
jealous in an attention-grabbing kind of
way because
in all honesty he has been a little
spoiled in kova times because mommy and
daddy have been around a lot more
so he's had a lot more of us to to
to spend time with us more often um and
also he's into this like game where he
calls mommy mommy mommy mommy mommy
mommy mommy mommy mommy
until you kind of acknowledge him same
with daddy doesn't matter whoever is
around he will just call
on repeat um and so i expect that might
get worse but we'll see
but one little quick tip that my mom
gave me because i think i mentioned
that my mother was a montessori teacher
so she's been dealing with young
children her whole life
and she told me a trick that she used
that they would use in the school
where they would teach the children to
put their hand on the adult's shoulder
when they want their attention
and when the adult was ready for them
they would you know turn to them and nod
to them and say
yes so and so um and that's how
they were being taught patients and so
we're trying that with my son he's still
a little bit young to totally embrace it
but i think he's gonna get it before the
baby comes
so i'm hoping that we're gonna build up
some of those patience skills
before baby number two comes but
honestly i'm not worried i'm not worried
about him hurting the baby
i'm not worried about him getting you
know throwing too many tantrums he's
just
very affectionate and and gentle in his
nature
so i know he's going to be an amazing
big brother
well folks i'm going to go enjoy the
outside you can see the sun is just like
beaming on me and it's getting really
hot in here
um not the most flattering light that's
for sure but
i'm going to go enjoy the day and on
that note uh if you like this video
don't forget to give it the thumbs up
don't forget to subscribe and ring the
little bell so you never miss a video
um also leave me comments below if you
have any questions about pregnancy
postpartum
breastfeeding i'm definitely gonna be
talking a lot more about breastfeeding
after this baby comes so
be prepared for that and i will see you
next time on abby's kitchen
bye